Перехоплюйте! Це пам'ятник.
Ви ж не можете забирати звідси, так?
Просто так не можна забрати. Це є зазначена дорога.
Знали, що тут був цвинтар...
Раніше, коли ми сюди перейшли жити, було якось так трошки тривожно
Зараз вже привикли.
Невідомо, що це за люди, коли вони були вбиті?
Невідомо, то це є ці люди, тільки були розстріляні.
Колгосп "Комуніст" у селі Чабарівка біля містечка Гусятин на Тернопільщині.
Пам'ятник краху планової економіки - і приклад цинічної нерозбірливості у виборі будівельних матеріалів.
Упереміш зі звичайним камінням - уламки мацев. Єврейських надгробків.
Тут бачимо зірку Давида - частину.
Ось ще частина від нього - у дерево врослася.
На цій території радянською владою було збудовано корівники,
у фундаменті і частково у стінах яких використані надгробки,
вивезені з єврейського кладовища у Гусятині.
З приходом нацистів почали руйнувати кладовище - і цю ганебну справу завершили комуністи.
Про те, що корівники збудовані з могильних плит, стало відомо декілька років тому.
Нині активіст Сергій Марцінко і його друзі-однодумці намагаються виправити помилки минулого.
Бачите - оце все надгробки. Це. Це. Це.
Бачите: це також частина жіночого надгробку.
Минуло 80 років відтоді, як останні євреї пішли звідси.
І люди забули про євреїв.
А вони 400 років тут жили - величезна громада. Це старе єврейське містечко.
Бачиш - край і лінія. І товщина однакова.
Зараз шукатимемо фрагменти, яких не вистачає.
Як мозаїку збираємо. Іноді сидиш, і голова обертом йде: це пасує, це - ні.
Знайдені мацеви активісти складають у стоси - зображенням усередину,
щоб дощ та сніг не пошкодили старовинні написи і візерунки.
Кінця-краю роботі немає - мацеви розкидані на території площею кілька гектарів.
Багато надгробків - все ще у фундаментах і стінах.
Ви питали, чому я це роблю. Уявіть собі: люди жили тут разом.
Євреї, християни, православні, католики жили разом на одній землі.
Діти росли, бавилися разом. Один до одного в гості ходили на свята, пригощали один одного.
А тут раз - їх не стало. Трошки соромно, щоби забути про тих людей, з якими разом жили.
Якось це не по-людськи. Ми, українці, культурна нація? Я вважаю, що так.
Хтось зробить тут - тобто ми. Хтось зробить в іншому місці - можливо, візьме за приклад.
Знайдені мацеви активісти поступово перевозять у Гусятин.
Складають пам'ятники біля будівлі колишньої мікви -
єврейської ритуальної лазні, що розташована неподалік від - теж колишньої - синагоги.
Це з села Суходіл - чоловік витягнув з річки трактором.
Цей Антон знайшов - діти на подвір'ї щось робили і знайшли.
Одним словом, тут звезені надгробки, які були розкидані по території Гусятина.
І не тільки Гусятина. Ми вирішили перевезти їх сюди, щоби хтось не використав їх повторно у якості будівельного матеріалу.
З уламків, як пазли, активістам вдалося зібрати декілька десятків мацев.
А знайома експертка з юдаїки допомагає перекладати написи на івриті українською.
ЩО ДАЛІ З НИМИ?
Повернути їх на кладовище - на їхнє місце, де вони були.
Покійникам повернути.
З цих надгробків, які нам вдасться перевезти сюди, хотілося б -
так було би правильно - створити меморіал у вигляді стіни на кладовищі.
Живим це потрібно для того, щоб пам'ятали і бачили, розуміли історію міста, в якому ми живемо.
Ці на перший погляд звичайнісінькі пострадянські подвір'я - колишній єврейський цвинтар.
За радянських часів тут побудували житлові будинки.
Приблизно звідси починалося кладовище. Воно займало територію 2,6 гектара.
З цієї території кладовища були вивезені надгробки в село Чабарівка і використані в будівництві корівників.
Під під'їздом одного з будинків - нагадування про забуте місце поховань.
Пам'ятні могили встановлені директором американського представництва євреїв колишнього радянського союзу Мейлахом Шейхетом.
Під його керівництвом споруджений такий меморіал.
Загальний пам'ятник про те, що тут - територія кладовища, а також пам'ятник праведнику-рабину і його сину.
Щоправда, те, що ми - на колишньому цвинтарі, зрозуміло і без цього.
Це перевернуто. Це опиралося на землю. Це верх. Це частина пам'ятника.
Громадський активіст Сергій Марцінко веде нас на своєрідну екскурсію територією місця пам'яті, що стало місцем забуття.
Людям дали квартири. Людина стояла у черзі, щоб отримати те житло.
Люди ж не винні, що їм саме в цьому будинку дали квартиру.
Багато людей, які отримали ті квартири, не зовсім, мабуть, знали, що будинки збудовані на кладовищі.
Будинок ніхто валити не буде. Так вже сталося - так є.
Але можна було б створити тут меморіал - подивіться, яка тут площа, яка тут велика територія.
Створити загальну стіну, в яку будуть вмонтовані мацеви - я думаю, що це реально.
- ЧОГО НЕ ВИСТАЧАЄ? - Фінансів.
Фінансів і, розумієте, потрібен проєкт, потрібна загальна картина, погодження, громадське обговорення.
Великі надії активісти покладають на порозуміння із новою місцевою владою.
Натомість ми вирішуємо вже зараз поцікавитися у місцевих мешканців, як їм живеться на колишньому цвинтарі.
А ВИ ДАВНО ТУТ ЖИВЕТЕ? - З 2002 року. - І ВИ ЗНАЛИ, КОЛИ КУПЛЯЛИ КВАРТИРУ...
- Ну, ми знали, що тут був цвинтар, ця могила була вже тоді, але іншого виходу не було - нас просто переселяли сюди.
Ми не купляли, нас переселяли. Раніше, коли ми сюди перейшли жити, було якось так трошки тривожно.
А зараз вже звикли. Ми знаємо, що ми нічого не змінимо і не в силі змінити, змирилися і так живемо.
ПАЛОМНИКИ СЮДИ ПРИЇЖДЖАЮТЬ? - Приїжджають дуже багато. Палять тут свічечки, папірчики пишуть, моляться.
Ми ж по-єврейськи не розуміємо. Просто трошки неправильно, мені здається, що під самим житловим під'їздом.
Ну, не знаю я... Як то кажуть, я  не вникаю в тую релігію, щоб я там розумів, чи його треба чи не треба.
- А ЯКБИ ЩЕ ПОБУДУВАТИ МЕМОРІАЛ ТАМ, ДЕ ЗАРОСЛІ ЗАРАЗ? - Най би там було, чого ж не можна?
Гарно зробили би місце, окультурили би його і все.
Схожа ситуація зі збереженням пам'яті й у селі Гусятин Хмельницької області на східному березі Збруча.
Раніше обидва Гусятини були одним цілим, допоки їх у 18-му столітті не розділила тодішня геополітика.
Західна частина містечка опинилася в Австро-Угорській імперії і згодом у Польщі, а східна - в Російській.
Аби потрапити із тернопільського Гусятина в хмельницький, переходимо через Збруч -
колишній кордон між могутніми імперіями, а нині - між областями України.
Дорога, якою ми йдемо, на перший погляд виглядає як звичайна сільська ґрунтовка.
Але побудована вона частково з могильних плит - єврейських і християнських.
"Здесь покоится прах раба Божия..."
Якесь тут є прізвище - Абакін.
"Представился 5-го февраля".
Так, і це пам'ятник. Він лежить написом донизу.
Ні, я його не піднесу.
Перехоплюй!
Спільними зусиллями все-таки підіймаємо могильну плиту.
Утім, на відміну від надгробків з колгоспу "Комуніст", забрати її звідси не можна.
Потрібні дозвільні документи від органів місцевого самоврядування.
Це є зазначена дорога. Просто так не можна забрати,
бо можуть притягти до відповідальності за те, що зруйнував дорогу.
- А ВИ НАМАГАЛИСЬ ОТРИМАТИ ДОЗВІЛ?
- Дивіться, насамперед, щоб щось писати, треба з людиною поговорити просто усно.
Ну, з цією головою, яка тут була, я говорив у кінці лютого, але розуміння я не знайшов.
Я буду писати до голови, який зараз виграв вибори,
і будемо намагатися, шоб це забрати, бо це є неподобство, так не можна, в цивілізованому світі так не роблять.
Це є пам'ять про померлого, та людина тут жила…
Потенційні місця пам'яті у двох Гусятинах - на кожному кроці.
У Гусятині на тернопільській стороні Збруча, активісти визначили місце,
де нацисти розстріляли місцевих євреїв, і наразі добиваються встановлення там меморіалу.
Є у селищі ще одне місце розстрілу.
Громадський активіст Сергій Марцінко веде нас до католИцького костелу Святого Антонія.
Настоятель храму, монах-францисканець отець Михайло кілька років реставрує історичну будівлю храму.
Утім, частину стіни священник залишив без штукатурки.
Тут ставили людей - було дуже зручне місце для тих, хто тут робив злочин, тобто розстрілював людей
- між колонами, щоб люди не мали можливості втекти.
Хотілося б зробити тут гарну пам'ятну дошку для майбутніх поколінь.
Щоправда, для цього треба спершу з'ясувати, хто і кого страчував біля стіни храму, каже отець Михайло.
Священник веде нас у підвал костелу - показати ще одну моторошну знахідку.
Воно тут було все розкидане, і вхід був просто засипаний.
Поскидали сюди, щоб приховати злочин. Засипали і думали, що воно так собі...
За радянських часів сюди лазили діти.
Отець Михайло каже, що ці кістки і черепи скоріш за все останки людей, розстріляних біля костелу.
Судячи по кістках, це з радянських часів, з часів війни.
- ТО ЦЕ НІМЦІ РОБИЛИ? - Або німці або НКВСники.
Може бути, німці свою роботу робили і НКВСники. Місцевих людей розстрілювали.
НКВСники скоріш за все розстрілювали віруючих людей, тобто тих, хто належав до храму,
а так само, хто належав до УПА - теж розстрілювали.
А коли були німці, то вони теж свою роботу робили чорну.
Деякі люди кажуть, що так само євреїв тут розстрілювали.
Мусить бути якась експертиза, якщо вона щось доведе. Ви перші журналісти, які потрапили сюди.
Скільки останків наразі ще закопані в підвалі - невідомо.
Отець Михайло сподівається, що після суспільного розголосу нарешті буде проведене експертне дослідження,
а місце злочину, хто б його не вчинив, вдасться перетворити на місце пам'яті для майбутніх поколінь.